فوفو جديد
سبورت طويل
تعرفون ان التوقعات
الروس من بدايه كانت ان تفرق بيننا ولكننا
متحدون والقواتها
ينبغي ان يعرف كيف
يتصدون
استراتيجيا وكذلك ان يحسنوا من قدراتهم
العمليه
ولكي يدافعوا عن انفسهم
وزير الخارجيه وزير الدفاع
عن ذلك
جدا والولايات المتحده همم
الوزير اه استنى اوصى بيزيل تعزيزي همم
دعمنا العسكري لكي تحقق اوكرانيا اهدافها
ودبابات ابرامز هي افضل الدبابات في
العالم وكذلك نقدم لهم قطع الغيار وندربهم
على استخدامه وصيانه وستبدا التدريبات
قريبا في اقرب وقت
الى ارض المعركه سياخذ بعض الوقت وفي ناس
يتم تدريبه عليها كما اننا اشتقنا اعلاننا
مع حلفائنا هناك ايضا اعلان من
توفيق الدبابات في الاسابيع القادمه
والمستشار شيلس اعلن انه سوف المانيا سوف
تقدم عددا من الدبابات لبرد واود ان اشكر
المستشار على
زعامته وعلى الجهود
وتعذيذه الجهود الجماعيه من اجل دعم
اوكرانيا
من ان تدافع عن
سيادتها وارضها هو التزام عالمي واسع في
الاسبوع الماضي المانيا
كل منها يقدم بدعما مهما لمساعدتي
اوكرانيا في المحافظه على اراضيها
والتصدي
العدوان الروسي المملكه المتحده اعلنت
انها تقدم
دبابات
اوكرانيا وكذلك عربات
مدرعه من فرنسا
والمانيا
من همم
المانيا
بمنظومات دفاعيه لتتمكن من حمايه مواطنيه
التي تتعرض للقصف
الروسيه
في الحقيقه حدث هو ان فنلندا ستصبح من
اعضاء حلو اا حلف الناتو
ثلاث الاف من العربات المدرعه ومن الذخائر
الصاروخيه
كله ذلك
الروسي لاوكرانيا
وهناك عمل تقوم به الدول
بقياده الولايات المتحده للدفاع عن سياده
اوكرانيا هذا ما يتعلق به الامر وهو
مساعدته اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وعن شعبها
وليس هناك تهديد بالهجوم على روسيا
سبونج هذه لو ان روسيا ارادت فان الحرب
ستنتهي اليوم
وينبغي ان يكون ذلك
بشروط عادله لا نسمح من ان من ان تهجم
دوله وتعتدي على اراضي
زياده
في اطار الامم المتحده
جنبا الى جنب مع جميع شركائها
خلفائها لدعم اوكرانيا همم
ويقسم ما بين همم اوروبا والولايات
المتحده وقد كان مخطئا كان مخطئا كان
هو مستمر في الخطا نحن متحدون الولايات
المتحده والعالم
واحنا نقترب من
بدايه الحرب فان همم موقفنا ما يزال موحدا
والدبابات التي
سنقدمها او ندعموا بها اوكرانيا تلعب دورا
مهما
معكم
اوكرانيا
سندعامها ضد الغزو والاعتداء
الولايات المتحده فخوره وهي معركه سنحرص
على ان تفوز بها ايطاليا
اوكرانيا لان هذه مساله حريه وهو حرب لا
نريد ان يراها اطفالنا اطفالنا والاجيال
القادمه ليحمهم الرب لتظل الحريه قائمه
شكرا
هاجي بس سجلناه
في جامعه كويس
هل اجبرتكم المانيا على ذلك لا هذا امر
توصلنا اليه معا